in a new episode of 60 minutes plus
correspondent seth doan
dives under the sea off the coast of
italy
he's uncovering what remains of the
sunken city of
baya which is known as the las vegas of
the ancient world
here's a look at what he discovered
brushing away sand reveals exquisite
slabs of marble
and these mosaics the flooring of
two millennia ago
the now sunken part of baya lies up to
50 feet below the surface
davide's underwater mapping has allowed
them to create these
3d models to visualize the more than 400
acres of lavish villas and spas
where emperor nero and julius caesar had
homes
bio was a seaside escape for the ultra
wealthy
with extravagant offerings including
fresh
fish from private saltwater ponds
davide showed us where toppled columns
once stood
and i ran my hand along steps likely
leading from a pool
you'd never want to go scuba diving just
to see fish again
while smaller artifacts have been
removed larger structures
remain creating an underwater museum
for tourists and divers for the first
time in over a decade
an entirely new neighborhood still being
investigated and restored
was open to the public last summer wow
that's so fascinating seth doan joins us
now seth good morning i understand
you actually learned how to dive to make
this trip
that's right somebody's got to do it it
was spectacular anthony to go down there
looking at those replicas of statues
that they have put down they pulled out
the originals to make sure that they
didn't get
deteriorated anymore but they want to
give people something
to experience and a lot of the bigger
things you saw how they were working on
those
mosaics those remain deep underwater in
some cases up to 50 feet
below the surface and the only way to
see that is to scuba dive so
yes i learned how did the city earn its
reputation as the las
vegas of the ancient world
it was this wild place really an
extension
of rome the capital about 150 miles away
but this is where
everyone would go to relax to unwind and
to play there are these
fabulous old descriptions and ancient
texts of
seeing drunk people walking on the beach
there's this one wonderful line about
how
luxury had claimed bayer for her own
resort it was this place there were
murder plots
it was this extravagant place which were
actually architects
also got to experiment they were testing
things out in some cases
using materials that then would later be
used in
in the capital in rome what did you
learn about the people who vacationed
there
rich wealthy powerful they went down
there because of this
volcanic activity that wound up being
the downfall of baya
they went down there because there were
these thermal baths and they built these
villas these elaborate villas along the
beach and you can see the money in
in how they spent the money in those
mosaics in some cases
really elaborate colors the reds coming
from egypt others coming from turkey or
greece
seth doan thank you very much it looks
just fascinating i wish i could go
you can watch this full report right now
on 60 minutes plus on the viacom cbs
streaming service
paramount plus